[Música]
bueno lo primero perdonadme chicos dt y
os dije que la científica y que venía a
hablar de ciencia pero es que me acabo
de encontrar con una amiga y en el
camerino y es que necesito que la
ayudéis así que bueno es extraño me
invitáis de verdad que vengo a hablar de
ciencia
os cuento tengo una amiga que se ha
apuntado a esto de tender
que sabéis lo que es tender
hay alguna cala roja no os preocupéis no
voy a hacer levantar la mano para ver
quién no usa pero que sepáis que hay un
estudio que dice que una de cada cinco
personas se ha descargado alguna vez
esta aplicación en el móvil
así que si hoy somos 1000 por lo menos
200 personas sabéis de qué os estoy
hablando y bueno para los que no sepáis
que extender y no viño es una aplicación
que te sirve para encontrar pareja a
través de terneros quiero presentar a mi
amiga mi amiga se llama agua y se define
entender como fresca natural dulce y
transparente yo sé que es un poco mayor
para estas cosas 3 mil 800 millones de
años son bastantes pero si la veis es
que por ella no pasan los años además
tiene algo
que una vez que la conoces no puedes
vivir lejos de ella y bueno tiene un
defecto a ver como lo digo así sin
ofender la un poco finalmente y es que
sí que es un poco fresca y claro tres
mil 800 millones de años dan para tener
muchos novios hoy os quiero presentar
alguno de ellos uno de los primeros fue
acueducto acueducto se define entender
como fuerte y buen comunicador pero agua
se quejaba que siempre había aquí donde
él decía y aún así estuvieron muchos
años juntos luego agua buscaba alguien
más joven más energético y encontró a
presa agua decía que presa la inundaba
de amor pero que cuando iban por la
calle a veces les miraban mal que debía
haber hecho daño a gente de muchos
pueblos y eso al final acabó rompiendo
su relación
y a ver que me acuerde uno de los
últimos novios ha sido lagunaje lagunaje
era muy eficaz en su trabajo y además le
gustaba mucho el medio ambiente y los
seres vivos como agua pero tenía el
problema de que lagunaje necesitaba
mucho espacio y cuando vivían en la
ciudad a veces era difícil dejarle tanto
espacio ahora agua estaba buscando novio
y la verdad es que tiene muchos
pretendientes pero necesito que me
ayudéis a que escoja uno que para mí es
muy especial trabajo con él en el
laboratorio y pasamos muchas horas
juntos se llama sistema bio
electroquímico y es muy muy joven tiene
menos de 20 años pero para mí es un
súper like claramente que para los que
no usáis tiende ello vino un súper like
se da cuando te gusta mucho una persona
yo sé que agua le gusta a él y que a él
le gusta agua pero que ninguno de los
dos se atreve a romper el hielo así que
hoy os quiero hablar de él y que me
ayudéis a convencer a agua de que es su
mejor opción estoy segura que todos
lleváis hoy un móvil
o un reloj o un dispositivo que lleve
una pila pues un sistema violento
químico se parece mucho a una pila pero
con la diferencia de que en su interior
tenemos unas bacterias capaces de
generar energía a partir de una reacción
química estas bacterias claro tienen que
alimentarse de algo y su alimento está
en las aguas residuales que nosotros
generamos
a ver yo sé que esto suena un poco raro
así que como no quiero ser inexacta
quiero que lo entendáis en profundidad
las bacterias degradan la materia
orgánica de nuestras aguas residuales
generando co2 y electrones estos
electrones son liberados a un material
conductor y gracias a una diferencia de
potencial se mueven generando una
corriente y ahora es cuando todos decís
que ha dicho esta tía
bueno pues como quiero que lo entendamos
bien os lo voy a explicar con un juego
vale quiero que se imagináis que soy una
bacteria una bacteria que degrada
materia orgánica generando co2 y
electrones
quiero que os imaginéis que los globos
son electrones y vosotros sois mi
material conductor quiero que me vais
todos los electrones de un lado a otro
de la sala quiero que veáis como las
bacterias liberan los electrones y
gracias al movimiento de estos
electrones se genera una corriente ahora
vosotros sois el material conductor sois
el cable que permite generar esa
corriente eléctrica
ahora os gustan más los sistemas de
electro químicos ya
bueno muchas gracias por seguirme la
corriente
y estos electrones no pueden estar por
aquí toda la charla t
estos electrones necesitan un sector
final de electrones eso necesitan
alguien que lo recoja un sector final de
electrones
pero en la vida real es el oxígeno el
oxígeno coge los electrones y junto con
protones se reduce generando agua en
resumen las bacterias degradan la
materia orgánica generando co2
electricidad y agua pero es que un
sistema electro químico no solo sirve
para generar electricidad es que sirve
igual para un roto que para un descosido
ya os he dicho que sirve para depurar el
agua pero también sirve para desalinizar
la sirva para recuperar los nutrientes
que hay en él o incluso sirve para
capturar co2 si es que quiere no quiero
algo así no
bueno a ver tiene un defecto sistema
electro químico es nuevo en el
laboratorio y como todos los nuevos
necesita mejorar
pero yo creo que ya está preparado para
mantener una relación con agua si es que
de verdad que yo veo las chispas así que
por favor si veis a agua luego que
seguro que la veis ayudadme a
convencerla de que es su mejor opción
recordad que se llama sistema bio
electroquímico bio porque tiene
bacterias electro porque produce
electricidad y químico porque la produce
a partir de una reacción química yo sé
que el nombre es raro raro raro pero
estoy segura que a partir de ahora
cuando lo escuchéis sabréis de que os
están hablando y bueno si queréis saber
algo más de mí os dejo mi perfil de team
der vale de verdad que otro año si me
invitáis me pongo la bata y hablo de
ciencia y hablo menos de amor muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]